ねあの大きなと起きたっていうポニーが入ってね 沖縄県のかわいそうそれであのインナミ先生にあの
2人で引っ張っていただいてそういう始め方をしたんですね まだあの小学校の頃
いうまで
いうまあ 長くじゃなくてねあの2つ馬を片っ方に先生がノリになって
あの同じくらいの大きさの馬に私が乗ってあの 風なでを
のマイドイって始めようでそのうちあのそれを取ってしまったんだけどうまいあの 一緒によるものと思っているんですよね
ん
何年か前に柳屋さんのお母様とここで食事
昔は
あの軽井沢の駅間に カシウマがあって
お友達がお店に行くときに
カシウマに乗って行ってたのよって言われたから
カシウマ?
そうそれでそのそのそのそのまた本当の初めの頃はねあの乗れるかどうかあのちったい本当に小さいババがあって
あの一応の乗せてあの見てもらって
そうするとあの街に一人出してくれたんですよ
そういうとしょうがんのってあの自宅のあの別荘まで来てね
あの両親に今日これに乗ってるのよとか言って
えええええええ
それでももう道を一人で自由に歩かせてもらって
それはもうあの最近は全然もう車が多くてね危ないでしょ
本当にすごい大昔よねすごい年ですもんねもうね
一応乗れるかどうかジャッジしてもらって
はいあの
はいあのただ本当にあの
なんていうのは輪乗りとかなんですけどあの
回って止めたりできるじゃなければいい
あの貸し自転車みたいにね
貸し馬も借りてお友達に
じゃあ普通に乗れるって
自転車乗れる
まあ自転車感覚ですね
でもじゃあみんな乗って乗れる
柳屋さんのじゃあお母さんも乗れるってことですよね
貸し馬乗ってかって言ったから
聞いたことないですけどね
聞いたことない
貸し馬でお友達の家行ってたのよって
でもそれってなんか
貸し馬って人がいるんじゃないですか
いや、引き馬ですかって自分で乗るんやろ
4つって
だからお一人で?
うんうん
貸し駅前で馬を借りてお友達の家行って
そう私もそれはやらせてもらえたんだけど
最初にあの見せなきゃダメでね